so I guess 2018 the beginning of the
month so it's time for another monthly
update video I'm going to talk about
what went on in July what we've got
coming up in August and as usual I'd
like to begin by highlighting three big
things that viewers might find
particularly interesting big thing
number one is sort of a personal one I'm
getting back to working full-time which
means of course for me working overtime
my kids were here for the last month so
I've been spending a lot of time doing
family activities and much less doing
the normal workload big thing number two
we will have several classes online
coming out that you can enroll in in the
reason IO Academy with me is your
teacher if you're interested in that
sort of thing you can find the link for
that below and big thing number three I
begin the semester I'm actually teaching
three classes here locally in the
Milwaukee area too from Arquette
University and one for the Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design all right
let's talk about July what took place
during that long month as I remarked
earlier I had my kids here so we did a
lot of family activities you know quite
a few excursions some of them just
walking down the street to the museum or
the library or the night market or other
things like that some of them involving
a little bit more of driving they went
to a lot of Taekwondo classes we signed
them up for a full month intensive in
that which was very good we also did
some hiking together and went to the
urban swings and all sorts of other cool
stuff did some cooking we are members of
a CSA so we had the farm share so lots
and lots and lots of family activities
events I didn't do too many events I did
my worlds of speculative fiction this
time we talked about Robert Howard's
Conan stories that was a very fun
conversation you can see the video for
that link to below we also had our
monthly stoic fellowship meeting we did
a
Sophia that's the societies of
philosophers in America were we have a
local chapter here we did our membership
meeting that was a good discussion as
well and of course we did you know the
usual online events with half our Hagel
and ask me anything and all those other
sorts of things as well I was also on
two podcasts one is called think hard
and I was on there talking about anger
and then I was on the money savage
podcast talking about stoicism and its
meaning for for money I think that took
place in July if I'm mistaken place in
June that's just a sign of how far
behind I got with all of the family
things I was doing I also did do quite a
lot of tutorial work interestingly
enough I picked up several new clients
and you know that that's great to do
some very interesting projects that I
got to work on continue doing my normal
coaching and philosophical counseling
work and also my ethics consulting that
I've been doing for quite a while I
worked on some course building things
both for the the academic face-to-face
classes that I'll be teaching here in
Milwaukee and also for the online
courses that I'd hope to have up by the
end of the month but I'm gonna be
bringing out this month instead I also
did some podcasting work my son
interestingly enough has a real talent
for editing and and it was interested in
doing that so he edited some of the
podcast things not the ones that came
out this last month but things that are
coming up so that was that was fun for
us to work on together but I did bring
out podcast episodes finishing up the
series on play-doh and beginning a new
one on Kierkegaard's here and trembling
a text that I'll be teaching in the fall
in two of my classes and then videos
there of course was the event video from
the Howard discussion
I did get my six half-hour Haegele
videos done this month so that's nice to
meet my quota
especially during a particularly busy
time I started shooting some new core
concept videos on Blaise Pascal that you
may have seen somebody who I'm a big fan
of and I released a few additional Q&A
videos about stoicism so that was the
month of July didn't get quite so much
work work done but I got a lot of great
family time man and that that's very
important what do we have coming up in
August so there are a lot of events and
there's a lot of work activity happening
in August I'm setting myself a bar
that's that's pretty high let's talk
about events first so on the 7th which
is a Tuesday from 6 to 7:30 at the Frank
Weinberg library we have a quarterly
series philosophers in the midst of
history this time around I will be
discussing John Locke and his place in
history a very important political
thinker and also epistemologists and
modern philosopher in general then on
the 9th which is a Thursday from 7:00 to
8:30 p.m. I will be doing the next
worlds of speculative fiction were doing
the arthur c clarke one that was
supposed to happen back in june but we
had to cancel due to some injuries and
we're now doing it this time around so
i'm really happy we're going to talk
about you know 2001 and rendezvous drama
and all sorts of other cool stuff as
well then on the 11th which is a
Saturday from 12:00 to 1:00 p.m. Central
Time so make sure you check your
timezone we will be doing our patreon
exclusive philosophy chat that's for 4
patreon supporters of my work if you're
interested in becoming a patreon
supporter you can you know click the
link that's down below or you can also
see the card on this video on the 14th
from 5 to 6 p.m. we will have our public
half hour Haegele Q&A and discussion
session so if you've got any
questions about Hegel German idealism a
galleon ISM any of that sort of stuff
show up or if you just like to lurk and
listen you're welcome to as well on the
18th which is by the way my my birthday
from 12:00 to 1:00 p.m. I will be
hosting and ask me anything session
through YouTube live so you can access
that and and join in our session then on
the 25th of August we're having an
all-day Sophia workshop that one is
actually restricted to school their high
school teachers of English language
history social studies religion classes
and it's about incorporating philosophy
into the curriculum that's something
that we're putting on as a public
service then finally on the 30th from
6:00 to 7:30 we'll have our MKE stoic
fellowship meeting and that will round
up the month we also do have philosophy
pop-ups I announced my patreon
supporters when they are at the
beginning of the month for everybody
else you find out the day of announced
on my facebook or on other forums as
well one in YouTube live one in Facebook
live and I haven't yet decided what the
particular theme is going to be this
month I'm kicking around several of them
so stay tuned for that what else have we
got going on still continuing tutorial
work with a number of different clients
more coaching and philosophical
counseling work as well I'm doing some
consulting on several big projects in
ethics including working out a white
paper that has to do with with apps and
app development and I'm hoping to get
some writing done this month I didn't
really get any done last month so if
you've been looking at the blogs not a
lot of work there last month but I will
be doing a lot more this month
podcasting I'm gonna finish up the
releasing the Kierkegaard ones from fear
and trembling and then we're
gonna jump into the cicero stoic paradox
ones that my son edited for me and then
we'll see where we go from there might
be Heidegger might be epictetus I might
take some of the paschal stuff that I've
been shooting videos on and turned that
into podcast stuff although I might save
those for later video work you should
expect to see two videos from our events
the John Locke one the arthur c clarke
one of course the ama and the philosophy
chat get turned into the philosophy pop
up get turned into videos as well and
i'm going to be doing my half-hour Hegel
videos we're now in a new section which
is really cool
more Pascal core concept videos I've got
those lined up to work on for my patreon
supporters they will get a sneak peek at
some Kierkegaard fear and trembling
videos that I think I will be releasing
to the general public either next month
or the month after that so if you want
to see those videos in advance you might
consider becoming a supporter I'm gonna
do a few personal videos about things
that I've been thinking about recently
I've got a lot of book reviews to get
caught up on and do you know those so
I'm hoping to maybe knock four of those
out this month and then some more Q&A
videos there there's quite a few of
those that that could probably use some
discussion so that's what we've got
lined up for this month we're also
getting the schedule ready for 2019 for
speaking and other events so if you're
interested in bringing me in as a
keynote speaker or as you know a
lecturer anything along those lines
you're interested in hosting some sort
of event then you want somebody to do
philosophy related stuff you can write
me at Greg at reason IO calm and we'll
talk about that likewise if you're
interested in the tutorials
philosophical counseling coaching any of
those services so I hope you have a
great month of August I know that I'm
very excited to be getting back to
full-time work and
I'll see some of you at these online or
hopefully some of the face-to-face
events
you